[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab Roots the life
of her mind an interview series devoted
to learning how women think about their
research their field and their future
let's get started today we're in
conversation with Dr Alyssa Rhoden
principal scientist at Southwest
research sorry southwest region
just say sweary sweary is fine
yeah
principal scientist at sweary in Boulder
Colorado Dr Rhoden previously held posts
at Arizona State University where she
was an assistant professor of planetary
science Johns Hopkins University where
she was a member of the Europa Clipper
pre-project team in John Hopkins Applied
Physics lab and a NASA postdoc and then
Mission scientists at NASA's Goddard
space flight center
Dr Rhoden completed her BS in physics
with minors in math and planetary
science at the University of Arizona in
Tucson go cats and
her PhD in Earth and planetary science
at Berkeley her dissertation the
rotation and Fracture history of Europa
from modeling top modeling of title
tectonic processes set the stage for her
current work at sweary hello Dr Rhoden
and welcome hi thank you for having me
well thank you for coming back to lab
Roots I say coming back because my lab
Roots colleague Lawrence tognetti
profiled you in a piece entitled icy
Moon geophysicist mom and guitar player
how did that interview come about
uh well Lawrence and I go way back um he
was an undergraduate at ASU when I was a
professor there and he took a couple of
my classes uh and one of the things I
learned about Lawrence is that he's an
incredibly tenacious person
um so he didn't stop at taking a class
he found a way to join my research group
do a project
and we've really been in touch ever
since and
you know what I've learned about
Lawrence is that what drives him
fundamentally is wanting to do good in
the world and that's the kind of person
that I'm going to support all the way so
he asked me to do an interview and I
said absolutely
awesome wonderful
um and you know I I definitely want to
get to uh the the various aspects of the
title of that profile along with other
items
um uh let's start with uh icy Moon so
did you pick Europa uh because being an
icy Moon geophysicist sounds really
freaking cool because those of us who
know nothing about it
um no uh I wish I could say that I did
but no um actually it so it's a bit of a
it's a bit of a backstory um situation
but uh so I started in college in a
physics major I really struggled in
physics I did not have an easy time and
I decided that I was going to quit um
physics I decided that I should do
something that I was more gifted at I
had more natural ability for
um and I should let the the clearly
genius scientists in the room uh take
over take over for me in physics
um because of that I I found planetary
science and when I did it changed
completely my my feelings towards
science I realized that the things that
were missing for me in physics and
astronomy were still there in planetary
and and specifically the fact that you
have tangible objects to look at and be
curious about it was much easier for me
to to get excited about
Europa Enceladus you know all the
planetary surfaces and wonder what is
going on there then to think about Dark
Matter gravitational lensing the kinds
of bigger picture things that the
astrophysicists get really excited about
but for me it was a little bit too
abstract and um couldn't couldn't see it
you know
um so I applied for uh NASA
um what do they call it space Grant
Fellowship so this is where NASA pairs
an undergraduate student with a
scientist at a university I put in my
application during a very difficult
period in my life I thought surely I
won't get in
um and I remember the day that I got the
envelope and I thought I was having a
rough time and I was just like man the
last thing I need is a rejection letter
today and then I thought wait a minute
it's a big envelope
they don't send the rejection letters in
the big envelopes um so sure enough I
had been selected they paired me with a
professor named Richard Greenberg at
University of Arizona and he is the
person who introduced me to Europa
before I started working with him I did
not know that Europa had an ocean I did
not know about its gravitational
interactions with its other neighboring
moons I didn't know
um really anything other than planetary
science is cool and I like it
um and so we worked together for five
years uh through the end of my undergrad
and then while I was applying to
graduate school
um and so that is how I came to love
Europa
so so you mentioned that you you
believed
um maybe it's true but you at least
believe that you you you weren't very
good at at physics yeah and yet you
you're still getting I don't know if
it's it's by a different route or or
just thinking about it differently or if
truly studying um planets is different
from the physics done
um let's say in like cosmology and and
other areas but so so I'm having a hard
time thinking about how you do what you
do and yet which is really tough and yet
you are you say you weren't very good at
it yeah right so I think this is the
challenge
um probably in a lot of fields but
certainly my experience in in physics
and astronomy there's this feeling that
either you are a gifted and you can do
this or you're not right and you
shouldn't be there and I and I don't
know how much of that comes from the top
versus how much we allow ourselves to
believe is from from the bottom
um but that was how I felt uh I needed a
lot of help I needed a lot of support I
needed to go to tutoring sessions I
needed to go you know meet with my
professors and it seemed like most of
the students uh who are my peers didn't
do that and they just kind of got it and
you know what I what I came to realize
through research and through working
with Rick in particular was that I just
have a different style of thinking about
problems and I have different talents
um and the tough thing is you don't
they're not necessarily the easy ones to
gauge with an exam or you know with test
scores or grades
um I'm at heart a creative person and I
think about problems holistically and I
like to put ideas together
um and that's actually been really
fundamental to my success in obtaining
funding because it turns out writing
proposals is a creative process
um I've been able to build really
amazing teams of people to work together
because I have very strong interpersonal
skills also not a thing that gets touted
a lot in science uh so so when I say I
had trouble maybe I maybe I didn't have
more trouble than anyone else but I felt
it more acutely because the way I was
different made me feel like baby I'm
just I'm just wrong for science right
um and now I now I feel very differently
you know I think that
no I will never be the analytical you
know
standard old white man right in in an
office alone with lots of books writing
equations like that's not who I am
um but I can contribute to science in a
different way
and I have found people who who also
contribute to science in different ways
and what I realized is that if we only
want if we only have models of one kind
of scientist we will only create one
kind of scientist and we can only solve
that one kind of problem
um so that's how I reconcile those two
facets so so okay so a bunch of really
interesting things are going on so so on
I definitely want to press on on the uh
connection to creativity but but first
when you started talking about how you
weren't in your own mind anyway whether
it was top down or just sort of out
there in culture
um sort of the standard science student
and I was thinking about what for me um
comes to mind is what I hear from uh
logic students in my discipline
philosophy you know they they they think
that if they don't get it right away
that somehow there's something wrong
with them you know and I say well we've
got sort of two camps of a learner we've
got the people who just get it and they
don't understand why other people don't
get it and there's a benefit to that but
there's also a big drawback and then you
know the people who don't get it right
away
um but who work really hard and then the
benefit to that is they can explain it
which yeah right so right we tend to be
the the better teachers because we have
more understanding of the challenge and
where people where people might get
stuck
um and yeah I totally think the people
who are just gifted just naturally get
it they should definitely follow that if
that's their passion like definitely do
that but that doesn't it's not the only
path like you said it's not the only way
to get there and more importantly as I
was saying before I think we need both
kinds because the way that you're going
to express your skill set is going to be
completely different so yeah I agree
with you and and
piggybacking off off of that two more
threads uh come to mind one is I'm
curious about
the the fact that you were nevertheless
tenacious like you didn't just say oh
well I'm gonna go into the music program
because I play guitar right I'm Gonna
Leave science all together you stuck
with the Sciences so that's one point of
of uh interest
um and then the other has to do with
sort of developing the the different
ways of doing the same thing and I was
thinking um when I'd like to ask you
about your time in in Academia you still
obviously you are a researcher but but
now principally so literally yes
um and you know how it is that that a
lot of people I think get maybe pushed
out of academic life because there's
this pressure
in research at research institutions you
know to publish publish and maybe in
this in the physical sciences there's a
sort of bright burning star that burns
out rather quickly whereas in other
disciplines it takes quite a good number
of years to develop right
um stuff that you think is worth
publishing so um I'm curious about your
thinking about being able to to work at
UH a pace that I think is
um I don't know if pace is the right
word but I want to ask you also about
whether or not you think that um not
having the pressure the tenure pressure
um helps you do better work overall but
but first you say something about why'd
you stick with it why not because you're
a guitar player well so it's funny that
the guitar thing keeps coming up because
I only started playing guitar about
three and a half years ago so that was a
new that's a new thing but I was always
I was always an artist so when I first
started undergrad I was trying to be a
physics major with an art minor uh and
that was my original plan I wanted to do
Studio Art my mom was an artist in her
when she was a teacher but she was also
an artist she went to an art school for
high school and so this was a thread
that had been going through my life
unfortunately
Studio Art and physics have something in
common which is that they both require
three hour long one-credit lab courses
in addition to whatever else you're
doing so very quickly I ran out of time
to actually do Studio Art and physics
together so it's but I but I picked up
guitar about three and a half years ago
and it was really wonderful it was the
first time in regarding an instrument
where I picked something up and I
actually like they geared it out
whereas I played violin for like eight
years as a young person and it just like
was just as bad at the end as it was at
the beginning
um so so I do I have a guitar in my
office it's over there um her name is
Stella and what Della Bella Bella yeah
um so
it's been a it's been a really lovely
thing to add into my repertoire but um
to get to your initial question why did
I stick with it uh the big reason was
that I that I fell in love with planets
uh so when I decided to quit physics I
signed up to be a pre-law that was what
I was going to go into instead I thought
I'm good with people I'm good with with
talking you know debating I I this will
be a good fit and in order to go down
that route I needed to take a natural
science elective course and I ended up
signing up for whatever was available
which happened to be a class with this
very Grand name
um universe and Humanity origin and
Destiny
yes and yeah the first day that I went
um the professor did a tour of the solar
system
and it was the first time I'd seen a lot
of the images of the moons of planets
I'd seen you know the planets for a long
time and I just didn't realize how much
more we knew than we had known when I
was a little kid and and I was
fascinated and by the end of that
semester I just felt like this is this
is the thing that I want to study this
is the thing that I'm passionate about
and I just had all this fear that maybe
you know maybe I'm never gonna be able
to do it because I and I got to see in
calculus my mom told me you'll never get
into grad school that's what she said
um and and so I was really scared like
maybe yeah maybe I won't maybe I won't
finish my degree maybe I'm not going to
get into grad school maybe but but I
thought you know
I might as well just go until I can't go
anymore
um
so that's that's kind of how I went
along
um I will say things change for me a
little bit uh when I turned 23 I had a
midlife crisis I didn't get into grad
school the first year that I applied um
just by having applied to nine schools
and having first author papers and all
the things I got rejected from
everywhere and I was like man I don't
know what I wanted what I'm gonna do
with my life you know and uh my mom
passed away young and so when I hit 23 I
started realizing like man you know she
was through half her life when she was
23 and if I was through half my life
like this is not a question you want to
ask at 23. like not I mean unless you're
like an Olympic Athlete or a celebrity
of some kind 23 is a bad time to be
thinking about this
um but I you know I was just like man I
I haven't been able to do anything in my
life and I've always been trying to you
know trying to get through school and
and take care of my family and all these
things
um and so I I came to this this place
days of like I can't just do one thing I
cannot just do one thing because because
then uh life will be over and I'll have
only done that and so I made this
commitment to myself that even though I
wanted to try to continue in planetary
science I was also going to travel I was
also going to be an artist I was also
going to have a family I was also going
to do all of these things and you know
if it meant that I didn't go as far or
as fast as other people
that was okay with me because I needed I
needed to just live
today and and now and not wait sticking
with it
um
yeah so so there's something interesting
I think about about how
your how you were by the time you got to
planetary Sciences in other words
um you weren't sort of a wilting flower
that went oh I'm no good at physics I'm
gonna go run off and do something else
um you it I I you know it's it's clear
that you had a enough of enough
confidence in your intellect to say well
I still am interested in these other
things and this is rather fascinating so
I'm going to pursue it as far as I can
go
um and then now how did you end up
um recovering from the
um grad school rejections because again
you know a lot of folks might just say
oh well this is some sort of sign that I
don't belong in this you know discipline
I mean what what what got you through
yeah yeah this is a this is a good
question but it also makes me chuckle
because to this day I have days where I
think
um maybe I'm just not good enough maybe
this is a sign you know my proposal
didn't get funded I didn't get an early
career award I I haven't been invited to
give a fancy talk like there are an
infinite number of things and every time
one of those things come up comes up
there's that feeling of like maybe this
is the the proof that I was never
supposed to be here
um and so now
now I'm able to say
so
I'm here right I'm here and uh and
people want to work with me and people
find my work interesting and you know if
I if I wasn't good enough or wasn't
meant to be
okay but but I'm here so I'm gonna stay
and I'm gonna dig in and do it
after back then it was incredibly
difficult I I had
just confidence crisis after confidence
crisis through all the end of undergrad
trying to finish my degree in physics
never feeling like I had aptitude for
physics not getting into graduate school
was a huge blow
um
and the second time I applied I I got
into one Berkeley and that's it and I
remember saying to Rick that you know
gosh you know what did I trick them like
what how did they how well why did they
allow me in and he said
um well I just have to wonder how
everyone else didn't see it
and
you know he
is the reason that I'm a scientist like
he saw something in me he never let me
doubt it
he always believed that I could do this
and really just about every good thing
in my career has come from the fact that
I worked with Rick my postdoc advisor
was his graduate student we met and
became close friends and collaborators
then we are still close with libraries
he called me uh just as we were getting
on the on the phone
um we talk almost every day
and same with my job at sweary the
person I went to to come out here and
and have a a little bit of a summer
break which led to me being hired is
someone that I met through Rick and you
know he really put a lot of effort into
introducing me to people to to kind of
um
not really sales pitching but like
making sure people knew I was giving a
talk talking about my research
um he really taught me what it meant to
be a scientist and and how to network
and all of those things so
um I don't think I would have stayed if
I hadn't had someone who's so clearly
believed in me in a new way or helping
yourself get unstuck if you're stuck or
something else like how how does
creativity play into your
um your research
um so there are a few ways and and in in
some ways they're very distinct and I do
them differently and I think about them
differently but there are a few overlaps
and one is that in both cases I need
space to just let my mind kind of wander
and Meander go where it's going to go
if I'm sitting down you know in front of
an iPad and I want to do a drawing or
I've got my SketchBook I can't just sit
down and say well what am I going to do
okay I'm gonna make a house today and
this is what it's going to look like in
it right I have to kind of move the
pencil I have to look around I have to
put music on it and it's just like being
able to pull from all the different
sources of stimuli really help me create
something
same is true in science I talked to my
colleagues not even about science
sometimes just go to the coffee room and
have a chat
um I I go for walks I get coffee
sometimes I work in a different
environment and all of that helps my my
mind to just sort of flow and be really
free and usually that's when I come up
with my best ideas I go for a walk
rain is going children are playing
there's a creek there's a duck you know
and all of a sudden it's like oh I know
the way I'm going to say this I know the
way I'm going to say this in this paper
or I know the way I'm going to put this
into into a presentation
so in that way meeting that freedom and
that flow is important in both cases I
think the other thing that overlaps is
that I tend to think about composition
and not like carbon composition but you
know the picture as a whole so whether I
am um thinking about a a picture that I
want to create
um or a song Sometimes I'm trying to
write songs uh so thinking about lyrics
or I'm trying to put together a new
proposal idea or work through a problem
I'm always thinking about how does the
whole thing come together right and
that's the starting point and then I can
take each piece individually and say
okay how am I going to tackle this one
individual thing
um but I have a very big picture thinker
and really not so much the little little
things do you and so so do you find kind
of once you've got the the composition
the the structure
um do you do you get do you end up
getting lost in the weeds and you and
like walking or playing music or
something kind of gets you back out
um again or is it is it more in the case
that one once you got it you don't get
lost in the weeds because you still you
maintain the hole at the same time
that's a that's more of that so because
I have a structure in my head the
composition in my head then I I feel
free to focus on something and and yeah
maybe I I do get into the weeds but
that's okay because you know I'm
stippling something to create shading
right like you need to focus on that
um
so
but but if I try to do it the other way
if I try to sit down and just do one
piece of something uh I get very
frustrated I have a really hard time I
don't feel like I'm making progress I
have to step back and have that sense of
like how does this fit why is this
important
um
and I you know a close friend once said
to me you only like to do things that
matter and I think in a way that's at
the heart of it it's like I have to see
how this fits into something that I'm
building uh otherwise I I don't
I just can't I just can't put the energy
into it I can't connect with it
um
yeah now you're a mom as well so so does
this also apply there or like do you
compartmentalize how do you do all of it
because oh my gosh principal scientist
you know and Mom and advisor I mean
you've got this and I'm training for a
triathlon and I'm in a band and I like I
just I know it's it's kind of crazy
um yeah so how do I do all the things uh
well first I allow myself to do things
badly
and and maybe badly's the wrong way but
like I I allow myself to to screw up to
do things 80 of the way you know and and
that helps a lot so
um quite literally I'm 70 time at my job
um I don't I don't work over that very
often
um and that creates a lot of a lot more
space for me to do other things uh when
I'm not at work most of my time is spent
as a mom
um I'm divorced I have my kids about 70
of the time so that translates to uh one
night off a week
um and the rest of the time I'm feeding
my kids and getting them ready for
school and I was late to this meeting
this morning because uh you know I
needed to pack their lunches and then it
was swim day and so we had to find all
their swim gear and then we would drive
all the way across town and
um so you know it's it is a lot and I
just I I'm accepting of myself being
five minutes late to things I'm
accepting of myself you know not always
not always being on top of everything
and if I can do everything that I'm
trying to do at least 80 percent of the
way
feel okay it's pretty good
um but no I don't compartmentalize very
much at all and I never have as soon as
I had my son
uh Henry it's my oldest
I just changed you know I just I hadn't
been certain I wanted to be a mom
um for for a lot of reasons
and as soon as I had him I realized no I
this is the thing that I'm gonna put my
life into and I still wanted to have a
career I wanted to be a role model to
him for what women can be I wanted to
make sure he didn't feel the pressure of
being my whole world I wanted him to
know he it could be whoever he needs to
be and I've got my own my own gig going
on and I love what I do but I always
wanted my children to have as much of me
as they needed
and and so they've gone on conference
trips with me they've been in my classes
uh when I taught the first day you know
you go through the syllabus right first
day of class and I always um also put in
a little bit about myself here's who I
am here's what I study and it's great
because I study moons right and so then
I would always put up pictures of my
kids talk about how I have two little
satellites of my own that orbit me and
you know and I just
some people probably don't like it some
people think maybe uh I'm not I'm not
professional enough or I'm not
um serious enough or whatever
I don't care I don't care like who I
want to be is someone who is a mom
and loves her kids and is a super
involved parent and as a scientist and
that means I'm going to be messy and
I'll be late and I'm gonna talk about my
kids a lot and some people won't like it
and that's okay you know because that's
who I am
well on the the fact that our our social
structure
has been created has been sustained as
it is for so long makes us think that
you know not having kids at work or not
talking about kids or not you know not
bringing your full self to your work is
somehow you know that's the way it's
supposed to be
um and I find that to be I'm like well
why right why that's the better way to
do it why isn't this other way Justice
right and you know that's interesting
because in some ways uh you're
encouraged to bring other aspects of
yourself people get really impressed
with you if you work and you are
training for a marathon they're like oh
my gosh look this person's dedicated and
strong and like all these great things
but if you're like oh I have to leave
early because my kids in a play they're
like man why are you so undedicated
right it's like it's a very strange it's
a very strange thing
um
it's very yeah it's very odd uh but this
is something I learned from my sister
actually she
has always brought 100 of who she is
everywhere that she goes and
you know sometimes it's it's caused
problems for her and she's still like no
this is who I am and take it or leave it
uh and I and I admire that a lot and
I've tried to learn from her that it's
okay it's okay if who I am isn't going
to fit in the expectation box or the
conventional box
um and I will find my space and I'll
find my people and you know and that's
okay well and I I hope anyway that in
maybe another I don't know if I'm being
optimistic but another you know three
generations there won't be a strict
quote unquote normal right there there
will be room for for everyone so that we
actually get the best of all the worlds
right which will make us all make all of
our lives uh better I would think um
yeah and that also maybe again
tangentially but brings me to a question
about leaving
uh research in an academic setting or in
a university setting and going into the
um the non-profit it is sweary is
non-profit it's technically a non-profit
but it's the same way that the Applied
Physics lab is a non-profit a lot of
these research institutions where you
know yes it's not for-profit but it's
it's not like the non-profit that people
generally think of where you're out like
helping feed the world like we're not
we're not doing that
um so yeah I there were a lot of things
that prompted my decision to leave uh
ASU to come to sweary and some of them
are more
um
individual and unique to that situation
and some I think are quite General
um
you know for one thing I I struggled in
Arizona I just I didn't enjoy living
there I wanted to raise my kids in a
place where their big feelings would be
more accepted and you know they they're
very they're also very creative uh
individuals and um and quite sensitive
and I felt like Arizona was not a
supportive environment for them whereas
here they show up to the dog park
dressed in Link costumes and you know
have sword fights and and people love it
people think that it's great and they
engage with the kids and uh it's been a
much better place for them and Boulder
is also a better place for me you know
it's it's cooler and you could be
outside all the time which is really
wonderful for me I love being around
water Arizona not known for that
um
yeah right and don't get me wrong like
there's a lot of great things about
Arizona too but this when I visited
just felt like a much better fit for me
and for from where my family was at the
time
um
but I think in the general sense
Academia the university environment
still has a lot of catching up to do to
make it possible to be a thriving
professor and a family person right and
and that's true for men as well
um the system was built on the idea that
you were going to have men who either
didn't have kids or had a wife at home
to take care of their kids so you did
not have to be worrying about taking
care of your house buying groceries
cooking dinner Child Care none of that
and even as we've evolved to a place
where universities are much more
accepting of of women having babies and
being professors or men who are really
involved and have wives who are
scientists or professors or whatnot um
the infrastructure the rules are still
mostly on the books from a time when
expectations were very different than
they are today
so some challenges that I faced uh so I
had a three-year-old when I got the job
and I was six months pregnant
so yeah the first year I had an infant
yeah and uh and he would not take a
bottle so I was driving back and forth
to feed him later I was able to find a
nanny who could drive him to campus so I
could nurse while you know between
meetings
um and and it was it was a lot you know
it was a lot
um
you know people ask how I do it now and
I'm like well it's so much easier
well then it was then
um and so
you know there were a lot of a lot a lot
of rules and
then I was given a really nice signing
not signing bonus but um what do they
call it
it's a funding package when I when I
took the job to help me start my
research group and all this there's a
three-year cut off you got to spend the
money in the first three years okay
great so I gotta hire people I've got to
have students so I'm growing a research
group and I'm spending all this money
but I but that means I can't be slow
about it I can't I can't step in
um at a different pace because I have
this baby at home who needs me
um similarly you know most universities
will allow you to extend your tenure
clock if you have a baby but the way
it's implemented can vary the way ASU
implemented it you just add a year at
the end if you feel like you need it and
that makes sense if you have a kid in
your fourth year or your sixth year but
if you have a baby in your first year uh
it's like well that doesn't make me feel
better now it doesn't
um and the mid tenure review which
happens at about basically you turn
paperwork around two and a half years
that does not have an extension added to
it so I was going to be you know
assessed in the same way and against the
same metrics as everyone else who did
not have a baby in their first year
right so it's those little things where
um if you want if you're a university
and you want to be a place where women
can come in and have kids and be moms or
you want to have dads who are super
involved
you can't stop at the hiring point right
you need to to be really intentional and
thoughtful of you know how this person
is going to face different challenges
than than your traditional staff and you
need to be proactive about making sure
that they have access to support that
you listen to them when they say I need
this right and be willing to have things
look different right you can't you can't
say well you know this is what we give
everyone there for we can't give you
something else it's like no everybody's
going to need something different
um and you know the field has run into
this problem uh also with hiring people
from underrepresented uh groups right so
there was a university that wanted to
hire a black professor we don't have a
we don't have one we need one right okay
great wonderful idea except they
couldn't because every Professor they
had they they wanted to to interview
said well I don't want to work here
there's there's nobody who looks like me
right like that means um the environment
might be might be toxic it means y'all
haven't been doing very much to increase
diversity so I don't know what I'm going
to be up against it means I'm going to
be the black person that you want to be
on all the Committees so that you have
diversity of that right and that's a
whole lot more pressure right and then
it's not clear that that unconscious
bias has been dealt with so that you're
going to be reviewed fairly that you're
going to receive your promotions fairly
right like it's it's tough to come into
that environment you know it's it's that
same kind of thing and people have
learned that if you want to hire more
minorities you have to do cluster hires
you have to do more to show that like
you're committed Beyond well we we added
somebody correct you are to our staff
um so I think it's as we broaden our
access
by race gender
sexual orientation how much some mom you
want to be right uh we have to really
work to make sure that the institutions
can can support what people need
and you find so so you mentioned that
yes
um now as your children are getting
older but they're still young
um Things Are
less chaotic in terms of juggling right
um but but you know still you've got a
lot to to juggle
um how
is their room was there room at uh
places like uh sweary to basically to
negotiate for a a work environment that
allows you to take care of other
important things which in turn makes the
work that you produce you know ideally
that much better yeah so so that's the
interesting thing
um part of the difference between the
university environment and this
environment comes from the fact that uh
in the University environment it's
fairly rare for women who are professors
to have kids right
when you come out of that environment
and you go to research institutes most
of the women I know in research
institutes have kids and it's similar
with how involved dads are right there
are many more involved ads in the
research institute sector than the
university Professor sector and I think
that that is part of the issue so it was
no big deal to come to sweary and say I
can't be full-time I've got two kids at
home and I need some extra extra sick
leave because you know from day one I'm
gonna have kids who are going to get
sick and so I can't wait two years to
like build up a bank of sick leave right
so and and the person I was negotiating
with
is a mom she has two kids and she does
this job and she takes on way more than
I do right the um the the management
leader the section leader mom the two
kids right uh most of the women I work
with have children most of the men that
I work with have children and so it just
naturally becomes a more compassionate
environment everyone understands what
the demands are you if you go to so so
at ASU for example
um I I went to them I said well I might
need to pump right now I've learned I've
learned over time that many men and many
women have no idea what pumping is or
that it's a thing many okay because it's
not a thing they've ever dealt with so
for any of your listeners who don't know
when you have a baby and you need to
feed it and you're away from it you have
a pump and that holds the milk which you
then feed your baby Okay so until you've
had this experience you just don't know
and it's a huge pain in the butt if you
travel you need a place to do this if
you go to a colloquium on someone else's
campus you need a break and a place to
do this uh pumps are either manual which
takes forever or you need a place with a
plug okay which airports often don't
have right so once you once you have a
baby if you're if you're nursing if
you're bottle feeding with breast milk
you have to have this huge like mental
thing devoted to how you're going to
feed your baby right
ASU has one pumping room on campus
one
so right and so
it was it was a real challenge now
luckily my baby didn't take a bottle so
I didn't have to worry that much about
it but um but I had to worry about
transporting him okay so uh I had you
know there was a point to this
um
so when I when you're in an environment
where lots of people are parents it's a
really easy conversation to have Hey
where's the pumping room oh it's over
there how do you sign up for it oh this
is it when you go to a place where
no one is a parent and that's not their
experience and you say hey I'm gonna
need to pump and they say well can't you
do that in the bathroom
right
and you have to explain no I can't do
that in the bathroom or there was one um
postdoc ASU who came to me I wasn't
working with her but she was pregnant
I'd obviously been pregnant and she says
hey I I have a cubicle
in a room with a bunch of other people I
don't know what I'm supposed to do uh
and I said well you know we'll find you
a place to pump or I will come and sit
in the lobby with you and we'll pump in
the lobby and I bet they'll find us a
place
and you know luckily they did because
again you know I I'm trying not to be
hard on them it wasn't like ASU didn't
want to be supportive
right and they and they have these
things kind of in place and in motion
but they're just not there yet so for me
to come in and try to be successful it
was very challenging well and you I
don't think you're being hard on them if
we say well hang on a second here
why is the default position
[Music]
you having to go to your employers
supervisors whatever you know Dean and
say hey this is what I need instead of
them and then saying well can't you do
right instead of them saying okay
we have no idea what you might need
Beyond these things right tell us how we
can help you what can we do for you know
exactly I think would be the nice change
yeah that would be a useful change
um yeah and and this comes up in other
areas too I'm in a professional society
that runs a conference every year and
one day I was on the ones I was on the
the organizing committee
and I said okay what are we going to do
for for pumping and nursing you know and
uh they said oh well you know we put a
thing on the website that says if you
need special accommodations email you
know info apps such and such and I said
no yeah that's not gonna work because
imagine imagine humble me right I I need
to think about
my breasts
not a thing I really want to email info
at about right it's gonna go to someone
who could actually be like a man who
doesn't know anything about lactation
who also maybe is going to decide
whether my grant gets funded and now I'm
making him super uncomfortable because
I'm writing this blanket email about
like breastfeeding
um I said you need to have a specific
specific language says for lactation
needs or for nursing moms or something
that's very clear that this is going to
go to a person who understands your
needs right you've got to have somebody
in place who can be a true
um you know Ambassador and and person
you can reach out to and the person I
was talking to was a woman but she never
had kids she'd never had to deal with
this and she was like you're right I
would never have known if someone sent
me an email saying where's the pumping
room I would not have even had any clue
what the needs would be or how it would
work right so so this is the kind of
thing where you just need critical mass
of people with the same experience
before you get that stuff to be easy at
sweary at APL at some of the other
institutes I worked there because there
are so many more families and being
family oriented is much more common you
don't have to have the same
um barrier right that same uh gotta just
first explain what I even need
um and so that that definitely made it
easier to be here as a parent than to be
there
now um
speaking of needs and and there are some
some other you know far less important
questions like about you know Europa but
but but I but I would be remiss if I
didn't get uh to to some incredibly
important questions good okay Donuts
good yes yes so
um where did the donuts go let me tell
you about Donuts ah yes right snacks
Donuts yes so the story with the donuts
is this
um every Friday
at 9 15. everyone here in the the sweary
division 15 group has the opportunity to
go to the conference room and get a
donut and these are not junk Donuts
these are LaMar's Donuts and they're
amazing
okay so we get our Donuts
we go into the conference room and our
fearless leader Bill Bakke goes through
the week's headlines in space science
news
and it's incredible because for the most
part uh there's someone in the room who
is an expert in that particular area or
you know reviewed that paper
um or just hates everything about it and
so there's all these interesting
discussions and we we you know we go
whatever's whatever's on in the
headlines could be heliophysics so Sun
stuff could be astrophysics could be
exoplanets could be Europa lots of we
found modern water on Mars that seems to
be a recurring theme that we found water
on Mars
um
but it's great because you get to really
see what everyone's expertise is it's a
very casual environment it's very a bit
snarky so you get to really learn
people's personalities you get to learn
uh what the sort of pet peeves are
um or what the big like questions are in
in science so what are people arguing
about in the Mars Community I don't know
I don't do Mars right but I learn about
it in this way
um and and so it's a really fun way to
get to know uh your your colleagues and
there have been some good opportunities
where at the end of it I went up to
someone and said hey what you were
saying was really interesting have you
ever thought about you know doing it
this way so it's an opportunity for us
to really uh be interdisciplinary and um
cross fertilize I think is that's the
the new word of the decade is now it's
cross fertilized
um any donut holes or just oh don't oh
full Donuts yeah holes no we get full-on
Donuts glazed is the best but we get
cream filled and maple there's there's
also Bagels
um there's also fruit if you're
gluten-free
um we're very you know very inclusive
and coffee
um and it's delightful uh
it was something that I really missed
when we were all working from home
through the pandemic uh sweary in
particular does a lot to to get people
talking to each other and it's not
always in these very formal rigid ways
where we're only talking about science
um we have a big monthly lunch where we
we sit together and we all go to a
restaurant and usually sit with people
you might never otherwise talk to and we
have
um we have a monthly pizza lunch where
two people will come in and give talks
about literally anything right so it's
not just your science we had one person
come and talk about
um the the presentation he gave at
Comic-Con about
um yeah how martians have been
represented through history like why are
they always green and how have they
changed
um cool yeah we had one we have one guy
who uh his his hobby is
um recreating Star Wars memorabilia
so he actually yeah tracks down like
they use this type of you know tape
wheel and then they glued something to
it and then they use this lens cover and
now we've created the Blaster right
um so he brought in a bunch of his
um his stuff and we got to to see he's
got a Wookie in his office I think and a
bunch of stuff we had a woman uh whose
son is autistic and she came in and
talked about autism and and how to talk
to someone who has autism and what the
challenges are so it's really like more
personal than what did you present at
lpsc this year so they do a lot to
really get us talking to each other and
and it was very difficult when we were
all remote I don't think I realized
quite how much
of that energy eye sort of soak up and
and get excited about science and get
excited to to think about new problems
now did you
um so you're also a a Storyteller you uh
you know you participated in the moth
when you when you told me about that I
was just I fangirled all over them
exciting and and it was a it was a
terrific story is is that something
forgive me because I don't remember the
date did you do I don't know that during
the pandemic was this after uh
participating in these sorts of of
informal events at work or totally no so
so I started going to the moth uh soon
after I started working here so I moved
to Boulder I changed my whole life I got
divorced I became a single mom
um moved again like everything was in
upheaval and then I started to kind of
settle into my new life and the moth was
something that I had listened to on NPR
on the radio
and I don't know why but one day I
thought I wonder you know they say that
they're alive story slams maybe I should
look into this and there was one in
Denver I went absolutely nuts I was like
definitely going to this and the very
first one I ever went to is their
traditional Valentine's Day uh theme
which is Love Hurts
I went with my now dearest friend Julian
who works here with me
um and you know we're both single so it
was like Love Hurts on Valentine's Day
sounds perfect
um and it was just an amazing experience
people telling these stories
um they're five minutes long totally off
the cuff no notes right I mean you could
practice in your head but no notes when
you get up there and and you're telling
a story of something that that happened
to you you know true experience and they
were just so amazing and and everyone in
the room you feel the ways in which
we're all connected the ways in which
these things translate
um
and it was wonderful experience so after
that I started going religiously every
month I would I would go to the moth and
uh it took a long time before I worked
up the courage to tell a story
and I told a story
um at Love Hurts in February of 2020
that story
um won the story slam
and then everything shut down
at least you you you ended the
pre-pandemic uh yeah it's a lot of high
they did a good job so uh so I did that
story and then there was nothing for a
long time
um and then I came back when they
restarted again
um earlier earlier this year I think it
was when they finally restarted and it
was funny because the scores from Love
Hurts were still on the board from
pre-pandemic but it was wonderful you
know even even wearing masks even you
know having to socially distance and all
the things it was like it was wonderful
to still be in that environment
um so since then I've done uh three
three slams I have not I've not won any
um but that's okay
yeah I'm back into it I'm having a great
time I'm gonna do happy
um the next one in August and I think
yeah I think that'll be a fun one now
there's a there are a number of themes
that I think have been uh running
through this conversation but one of
them I I'd like to pull because I it
also allows me to ask you a question
about about Europa
um specifically but more specifically
dealing with stuff that's like really
far away yeah so so you mentioned early
on that you know the the the abstract
nature of so much of of what physicist
astrophysicists do you know it's just
it's it it's off-putting and you want
something that you can sort of wrap your
arms around and you've also
um
made a few remarks about
um the the sort of this
the benefits of sociability to your work
and your work life
um but here you are studying something
that is really far away like when I
think about outer space I think wow this
is really cool it allows me to remind
myself that oh thank goodness I'm just a
little speck I don't matter there's the
universe it's going on without me relief
but you know
same it's it's big and it's big and how
do you wrap your arms around that how do
you how do you get intimate with it if
you will yeah it's a good question
um and and there isn't necessarily a
clear answer you know some some of my
friends and colleagues they see a Galaxy
and they think
why how I want to know it right I look
at a Galaxy and I'm like that's pretty
like I don't and I don't know why I
don't right I don't know why but I think
everybody connects
differently with things and what you
find inspiring is going to be different
uh so I think there is just a
fundamental side of of what draws you in
um but in particular for me like
yes the moons of Jupiter are far away
the moons of Saturn are far away
they are reachable with spacecraft so I
have been using Galileo images Cassini
images and and it's like being there
right I mean I can see the surface I can
see uh what it looks like
as we start to go back to some of these
places we're going to see how things
have changed so Europa Clipper is the
next big Flagship mission that NASA is
sending it's it's thinking a launch in a
year or something like it's really close
now
um and those will be the first you know
comprehensive images and data sets that
we'll have for Europa since Galileo in
the late 90s right so so there's going
to be an opportunity to see more to see
how things have changed and that's the
piece that's that really starts to pull
me in right you can actually go and
observe test our hypotheses know for
sure right
um and that's true for for everything in
the solar system we can get there we can
see it we can figure it out
that helps me a lot what is your is
there if there is one what is your one
sort of Big Hope over the next like 10
years what do you what do you what
question do you want to answer
um
so it's tough because uh 10-year
questions are are actually kind of hard
because
I'm sorry no no this is it's fine it's
fine it's just it's funny because if
you're speaking to uh to a general
audience the kinds of big picture
questions you want to answer will take
decades right like there's a a Uranus
mission that we're going to develop
that's not going to be there till I
probably retired right so so a lot of
the bigger picture questions that are
it's clear why they matter are going to
take too long to answer in 10 years but
for me for the next five to ten years
the question I find most fascinating
is how did Saturn's moons form
so Saturn has a bunch of what we call
mid-sized moons so they're actually
pretty small they orbit
from closest to Saturn uh about
three Saturn radii away is the closest
one out to maybe 10 or 14. so they're
the close-in moons uh memes is the
smallest it's has a radius well so it's
a diameter of about 400 kilometers
400 kilometers it's not a lot of
kilometers
and its neighbor Enceladus is only about
20 20 bigger if you drew Enceladus on a
map of the world it would cover the
British Isle
it's small okay so these are mid-sized
moons pretty small moons
um and yet they all have a history of
geologic activity Europa is presently
has a global ocean under its ice shell
it has geysers that's actively spewing
that water out into the Saturn system
where it actually freezes and forms a
little ring of uh you know ice particles
um namus which looks like the Death Star
is looking more seriously it does if you
look up death star moon you'll find me
Miss they look side by side uh they look
identical
um but mimas were starting to learn may
actually be an emerging Ocean World
itself and it's one of these stealth
ocean worlds where you would not know
from looking at its surface what's
lurking underneath but we're finding
more and more reason to think that it's
it's at least a possibility and we need
to seriously consider it
um when we look at Jupiter's moons we
don't see anything like this Jupiter has
four big moons
um spread out much further than these
moons of Saturn they're big they have
this nice gradient where the rocky hot
stuff is close to Jupiter and the cold
Icy stuff is far away right the
mid-sized moons do not obey that rule
they're like whatever we're doing our
own thing
so so it's if you look at those two
systems side by side they're just
totally different and a lot of our
models are good at explaining how the
Jupiter system forms but uh but they
don't really account for the way the
Saturn system forms and so it gives us a
real opportunity to start thinking about
okay how do we how do we bring in our
creativity right how do we think about
this differently
um and
and once we sort of crack that open it
was like okay well maybe it's this maybe
it's that maybe it's this and now we're
having to go back and say okay well what
are what could we how do we constrain it
how do we decide what really happened
and that tends to be where I come in
because I'm very data focused and I
could say well there's a big crater over
here you got to make that crater so how
do we do that what is the evolution and
and what are all the things that happen
in the history of these moons that get
you here right so
um I tend to sit at that interface
between the theorists who are coming up
with totally new ideas and the
geologists who are like this is what it
looks like and I sit in the middle going
all right how are we gonna we're gonna
get these two together
um
that's the thing I would like to know
how did they form how old are they which
ones have oceans
and what does that mean when we look at
exoplanets when we look at
10 000 planets around other stars just
the tip of the iceberg of what's out
there which ones are going to have uh
planets which ones are going to have
planets with moons which ones are going
to have moons with oceans you know what
is the common way of building a system
what is the common type of of world that
you get and and so those are the
questions that are driving me right now
and and I hope that that when you answer
them you'll you'll come back
absolutely
libraries all the way yes excellent
excellent yeah well I I thank you thank
you thank you for being not only so
generous with your time but also with
your wit and your wisdom
um much appreciated and uh again
seriously I hope that I will be able to
have an opportunity to chat with you
again and learn more about your work
because your mind is fascinating well
thank you thank you and someday you'll
have to uh interview my kids too because
they've got some great ideas all right
I'm I'm I will be ready as soon as
they'll be they'll be ready real soon
make sure you have my cell we'll be good
all right great thank you thank you